welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss in Real Talk we're not feeling
great about Marvel right now are we
that's bad
Studios trying to quickly prune our
distaste for the secret Invasion finale
with a fun quirky Loki trailer first
thing at the top of the next week like
your Agent K telling us to look right
here and about Loki season 2 looks great
it does kind of look like it'll once
again be taking place in its own
continuity immune corner of the MCU
without really needing to address any of
the other phase four or Phase 5 Marvel
events because of that we can't really
get over the feeling that secret evasion
and other recent Marvel titles have so
weighted down the MCU with loose ends
and unresolved issues that'll be
impossible for the studio to bring back
the Glory Days at least not until like
2027 when we're all too spent and too
replicated by AI to care but you know
what I still believe in the MCU I think
his best days are mostly still ahead and
I don't think it's beyond redemption in
a recent video I diagnosed what went
wrong with secret evasion in the state
of Marvel right now in this video now
that we're starting to hear rumors that
Marvel might actually be finally closing
in on fantastic War casting and the
arrival of Galactus I want to add to
that diagnosis a humble prescription for
how Marvel could fix the MCU and
probably the craziest way my
prescription let Galactus eat MCU Earth
I'm not joking let him cook folks what
is Galactus cooking us we had our time
we'll meet again don't know where don't
know when I know I know I sound crazy
right now but I'm gonna get into it and
trust me by the end of this video You're
gonna be like you know what that might
work before we get into it though
sagaftra has informed us that
entertainment journalists like us are
allowed to cover movies and TV shows and
do our thing during the strike me
begging Marvel Studios to eat itself
obviously is not paid promotion we
support the writers and actors in their
strikes that they can make a decent
living while they tell Disney to let
them put into the Earth out of its
misery okay I think by now we all agree
on really the problems the secret
Invasion right regardless of whether or
not you enjoyed the series like I
enjoyed many aspects of secret Invasion
especially Olivia Coleman's performance
yet there's no denying the issues that
the series left the MCU with like the
implication that Roadie was a scroll
since the Civil War really doesn't make
any sense Gaia being so overpowered with
Captain Marvel level abilities that show
should logically with the Marvel's
upcoming plot link her to that crisis
despite her not going to be in that
movie and it seems like that movie's
centered around the unique personalities
of those three women Nick Fury once the
smartest tactician of the MCU the
fiercest leader always 12 steps ahead
and this series just made a series of
incomprehensibly stupid decisions and
left Earth in a worse State than how he
found it we learned nothing about the
millions of Scrolls still left on earth
and the president just declared war on
all extraterrestrials with no
acknowledgment of the Asgardian Colony
that black panther what kind of forever
told us he signed a trade pact with and
yeah a lot of people are just adding
this to the deeper issues Marvel fans
have had since Avengers end game that we
don't really know who the Avengers are
right now in the MCU when anyone's power
hierarchy is and why no one is talking
about the dead freaking Celestial in the
Indian Ocean other than a quick joke
about it and She-Hulk a show that by the
way acknowledge the existence of a meta
AI Overlord playing God with all of the
MCU storylines with no sense of how that
fits in with the other meta Godly
overseers of the MCU he remains in the
Kang Dynasty and that villain currently
being played by an actor whose career
future is a bit uncertain now in our
what went wrong video I diagnosed the
issues as my opinion a scale dilemma a
struggle by the studios to provide
Clarity around the Avengers and an
overall tonal identity crisis and in
recent days we've all seen a bunch of
prescribed fixes like Marvel should make
less Disney plus series or may should
make the episodes longer or do more
lower budget special presentations or
make shows more like Agents of Shield
and the Netflix Daredevil or just use
Kang and Deadpool to retcon timelines
all of which could work at least to some
extent like I could see Marvel trying to
retcon stuff especially with Deadpool 3
as that movie appears to be oh I should
say spoiler warning for set images for
temple 3 skip 2 this time to avoid it
Deadpool 3 seems to be aiming to kill
off the fox Universe by including a 20th
Century Fox logo pruned to the void
which remember the fox X-Men movies use
Days of Future Past to erase the events
of X-Men the Last Stand and X-Men
Origins Wolverine from continuity
Deadpool 1 and 2 made fun of and killed
the Weapon X version of Deadpool from
X-Men Origins but for Deadpool in the
X-Men it had been years after the pack
the upcoming Temple 3 was written before
secret division came out and everyone
decided they hated it so I wouldn't hold
your breath for Deadpool 3 addressing it
similarly I just don't expect Marvel to
roll out a Kang storyline in which some
Kang variant allies himself with the
cree to like prune all the Scrolls out
of existence and retcon the rhodium guy
issues Marvel has just never really
admitted to defeat like that like think
about it the least beloved Marvel films
from earlier phases Thor the Dark World
The Incredible Hulk both of these movies
received a kind of redemption a huge Arc
in Avengers endgame set during the
events of Thor the Dark World and pretty
much all the characters in that 2008
Hulk movie coming back in Shang Chi and
She-Hulk and in Captain America 4. but
there is another admittedly drastic
route Marvel could take and based off of
Clues might already be laying the
foundation forward Galactus now long
time new rock stars viewers know how
much we use geology and how long we've
been using it for but if this is your
first time hearing about geology get
ready for Blockbuster quality skincare
on a student film budget geology is a
23-time award-winning skin hair in body
care cup company recognized in men's
health Oprah daily hypebeast birdie
Esquire and GQ geology's products are
just a handful of powerful proven
ingredients that have been trusted by
dermatologists for decades geology can
help you fight acne reduce oiliness
prevent wrinkles combat dark or puffy
under eyes have smoother hydrated skin
and Target signs of aging everything you
need to keep your skin healthy no matter
how much you soak in the pool this
summer don't know where to start geology
can create a simple and effective skin
care or hair care routine for you all
you gotta do is take a quick 30 second
quiz right now if you use the code new
rockstars 100 geology will give you 100
off their award-winning skincare trial
set you'll also get an additional bonus
offer of up to 30 off one skin hair or
body products when you add it to your
trial it's truly a while to offer one of
the best they've ever given our audience
so click the link in the description or
go to
geolog.i.e rockstars 100 to get started
let's remember that the celestial's plan
for Earth was for for it to be destroyed
that was our destiny our whole existence
according to the gods of the Marvel
Universe was to just Elevate the
sentient Life Energy on the planet's
surface to feed a gestating Celestial
baby Tiamat in her core so that he could
eventually hatch and kill all of us that
plan was stalled by the eternals and
ever since the planet has bore a scar of
that decision with tiamat's corpse I've
made videos explaining how just this
corpse sticking out of our Stratosphere
would make life on planet Earth
unsustainable and Marvel has painted a
similarly Grim picture the future of the
MCU Earth in Loki's first season Loki
movies talk about escalating apocalyptic
events on the planet due to climate
change including a category 8 hurricane
in the year 2050 which is one of just
many disasters a climate disaster of
2048 a tsunami of 2051 the extinction of
the swallow that completely screwed up
the ecosystem according to Mobius and
Krakatoa the volcano re-erupting in 2049
the first time it erupted in the 19th
century it covered a third of the planet
in Ash the implication is that Earth
would eventually reach the point of
limitus 1 a moon that faced utter
Annihilation Earth on its current MCU
trajectory is not meant to last much
longer the celestials never intended on
the planet making it this far and here
is our chance to finally make eternals
make sense folks they can make it all
make sense they don't have to ignore any
of the history thus far now the United
States on planet Earth is pursuing a
crazy unilateral war path against all
extraterrestrials president ritzen was
so close to hitting the button to start
World War III and nuke everything Nick
Fury is like screw this increasingly
moving his operations outside of Earth's
atmosphere I just don't know how much
longer Marvel's heroes could or really
should keep a suit of armor around this
doomed planet in fact watch my breakdown
for the latest trailer the Marvels
there's just a couple clues in there
that seem to hint that this movie might
introduce Silver Surfer who is the
herald of Galactus could totally see
that in a post-credits scene so the way
the Thor movies let go of their past by
just letting Searcher destroy Asgard by
letting Ragnarok happen I think the
boldest and best move for Earth in the
MCU could be after Earthbound events
like Captain America 4 or Thunderbolts
another ground-based MCU titles let's
introduce Galactic and Fantastic Four
based off of the latest casting rumors
it seems like that's gonna happen but
rather than stating off his apocalyptic
event as superhero movies tend to do let
Galactus Feast let him eat us burn it
down now yes don't let everyone die like
save as many terrans as you can please
like get the Beloved Marvel heroes off
the planet don't bother waking up those
thousands of Scrolls in that basement
and lets Humanity live on a drift and
read Richard's space arcs then use
Avengers Secret Wars to assemble a
multiversal battle world and then just
reset the MCU reality with a clean slate
of continuity a true 616. only the
heroes and storylines and histories that
actually makes sense at this point
leading Galactus actually succeed in
consuming the planet will make him a
truly fearsome villain that we hate the
rage we felt for Thanos when he
succeeded in snapping away half of all
life but it'll also give many viewers
some catharsis to truly say goodbye to
the old era of the MCU while being
forced to be open to a new multiversal
reset with some familiar faces and some
new ones keep a lot of the adventures we
know and love but bring in a new Tony
Stark a new t'challa a new Natasha
Romanov Heroes for hire and Agents of
Shield and Miles Morales who were always
there and yeah maybe some freaking
mutants please what do you guys think am
I going too far with this should
Galactus win is the earth of MCU 19999
just too complicated and riddled with
plot holes to save at this point or
should we just put all of our hopes in
the Multiverse with Loki and Deadpool
and Kang to fix everything I don't know
I just think a bite being taken out of
the Atlantic Ocean is just more fun to
look at than like everything glowing and
pruning let me know your thoughts on
this hot take subscribe to all three of
the channels of the new rockstars
Network follow me on all social
platforms at eavos follow new rockstars
thanks for watching Everybody bye
foreign
[Music]